ER IMPORTANT NEWS I
ARE WITH MY VIEWERS
RIGHT NOASAWL
ROLL C
THE INVETO THE TRUMP
ORGANIZATION IS NEARING A
CRITICALCTNO.
NEW INFORMATION TONIGHT, THE
CHIEF FINANCIAARING N WHHE
COOPE  FEDERAL AND
JESSICA S E OR.CE CORRESPONDENT
TORS THERE
CLOSING IN ON WEISSELBERG?
THE QUESTION IS DOES HE
AGAINSRM TRUMP?
OR IF HE, POTENTIALLY
FACE CRIMINAL TAX RELA
TEARGES ON HIS OWN.THAT'S BECAU
INVESTIGATION INTO WEISSELBERG
FROM THE MANHATTAN DA'S OFFICE
AND THE NEW YORK AG'S
AT A AGE.
DICTMENT AGAINST OULD DE T
WEISSELBERG AS SOON AS NEX
MONTH.
BUISSELBER
THESE S IF HE DECIDES TO
THE'S BEEN W
THE TRUMP ZATION
NEARLY YEARS.
HE SERVES AT THE C FINANCIAL
OFFICER.
HELD WIDE WIND
IN DECISIONS ARE MADE AT
THE TRUMORTION.
THAT'S THEOBE HERE.
IF THE TRUMP ORGANIZATION VIOLA
X  F AND IF WEISSELB
BEE FORMER PRESIDENTRUBE, HIS OE
NOTORIOUSLY DOESN'T USIL
AND THERE ARE VERY FPLE
THAT CAN PROVIDEINSIGHT
INTO HOW THEMP ORGANIZATIOD WEI
SINCE THE CURRENDISTRICT
TO FILE THOSE CHARS IN THE AHETR
P ORGANIZATION CASE BEFORE
THEN.AND WHAT'S INTERESTING HE,
SCNI
WE LEARNED THAT MATTHEW CALAMARI
ISD AT FNG
SUBSIDIZENCOMPANY
CA PROSE ORS LOOK LOT.
DE CHARGES COULD
COME SOON.
>>SIK YOU VERY, VERY
MUCHGET SOME ANALYSIS.
JO THE FORMEEY ANDEN
AL, CN
ENFORCEMENT FICENDRE
McCABE, THE AUTHOR OE
ENTLE I E
ONGEOU
TRUMP ORGANIZATION,   ALLEN WE
IS G T WL,T REALENDS,
WOLF, ON HOWTIAL
INFORMATIOS NOLY
TO THEIR ABILITY BUT TNGNVESTIGF
PRENS ORGANIZATION
SO IF THE -- IF THDAHAT THEY HA
HED HIMSELF CHARGED AND
THE Y TO COOPERATEER.
BUT THE TIME TST TO AVOID
NG DOWN ON HIM. IS NOW, AN'S TH
>> AS YOKNOW,
ORTING THAWEISSELBERG IS STILL T
THE TRUMP ORGANIZAIN
MANHATTAN.
WHAT ARE THE CHANCES DO YOU EVEW
AND WEINAT COOPERATIONGR
VIEW?
S YO
POINTED W EVERYTHING.
A LOT OF THINGS.
N IDEAL
ISHA COOPERATING.
THARN
CONVERSATIONS BETWEEN THDA
OFFICE COUNSEL FOR ALLEN
WEISLBERSTATAVE THE OD
YOU., THAT
WE TTHE OTHER.
ARE YOU G USTHE GRAND JU
YOU SHOULDN'T.
THE EARLIER COMEAND
BETTER IT LOOKS
FOR YOU LATETHCT
YOUR SENTENCING.
WHAT WE KNOWO E LOOKS S G UMP O.
THAT'S NRER ORS. IN, AS YO
WHAT WILL MATTER IS HOW STRONG
THE CHARGES AREY BRINGANY, AND S
O ACALEEOF
OF PAT
THON AND WIT.
ACTUALLY IS.
BUT IT DEPENDS ON HIPERSONALITVG
COCOOPERATE, THE BETR  IGED THAA
AT THE ENDPL
WHO COMMITTED CRIMESY.HE THINGS
JUDGES LOOK ATN CIT
THE PENALTY SHOUE  WING
ILHOW EARLY THE
GUILTY, HOW  THEY
TRSETHD
ND PROSETO M SUBSTANTIAL
ASSISTANCE THE
OTHER PEOPLE
TO THE MIX.
TIMING INOT THE MOST IMPORTANT
ONE OF TNGS. T HAPPENS, YOUW,
THE COVERAGE S THEY HAVE AS TO
TAF
RECORDS FROM ACCOUNTANTS, FROM
OTHER EXPERTS.
OTHER PEOPLE WILL BE CAL
T THE GRAND
JURY AND EVENTUALLY A TRIAL IF
CHARGES ARGHT ANS
LL
T THE MANHATTAN'S
DA'S O
STRONG A CASE ASY N.Y WANT MR.L'
THAT.
IT'S IMPORTANT MENTIONED,
THIS ISN'T JUST MR. WEISSELBERG
ADVAAGINTOE A SUCCESSFULCONVINC
AND ITEARSTRNGTIONED TO FORWARD.
THE RIGHT TH